TOTAL ANNIHILATION STEPPED
OUT OF BOUNDS.
WATCH THIS.
>> THEY WILL BE MET WITH
FIRE, FURY, AND FRANKLY
POWER, THE LIKES OF WHICH
THIS WORLD HAS NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
>> ROCKET MAN IS ON A
SUICIDE MISSION FOR HIMSELF.
AND FOR HIS REGIME.
>> DO NOT UNDER ESTIMATE US.
AND DO NOT TRY US.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT WAS
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO
REMARKABLY.
HOW DO WE GET FROM THAT TO
WHAT WE ARE WATCHING RIGHT
NOW ON OUR SCREEN.
BYRON YORK HAS COVERED ALL
OF THEM.
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT AT
THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
BYRON, REVERSE ENGINEERING
THE LONG ROAD FROM THERE TO
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
HOW MUCH OF THIS WAS
INTENTIONAL?
HOW MUCH OF THIS UNFOLDED AS
A PLAN OR A STRATEGY ON THE
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION?
>> WELL, THERE WAS A
STRATEGY TO DO SOMETHING
NEW.
I MEAN, THIS IS SO
EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE IT IS
A PRESIDENT TRYING SOMETHING
NEW.
DONALD TRUMP IS CRITICIZED
FOR VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING HE
DOES.
BUT HE HAS BEEN PERHAPS
CRITICIZED A LITTLE LESS FOR
THIS.
BECAUSE NORTH KOREA IS A
PROBLEM THAT NO PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
EVER BEFORE ANYWAY.
IF YOU GO BACK TO THE 2016
CAMPAIGN FOR ALL THE TIME
THAT NORTH KOREA NORTH KOREA
HAS TAKEN IN TRUMP
PRESIDENCY IT, WASN'T REALLY
A HUGE THING IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
WASN'T A BIG THING IN THE
G.O.P. PRIMARY DEBATE NOR IN
THE GENERAL ELECTION DEBATE.
AND I THINK THAT WHAT TRUMP
IS DOING HERE IS SOMETHING
SO NEW BECAUSE.
HE WOULD CRITICIZE AND
PLEDGE TO DO UNDO WHAT A
PREVIOUS PRESIDENT HAS DONE
NOT ENGAGE.
ENFORCE THAT IDEA?
WHY WILL FIND OUT.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WILLING
TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAN HIS PREDECESSORS.
>> VERY QUICKLY, SINCE YOU
ARE PART OF THE PRESS BUT
YOU ALSO WATCH CAREFULLY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
NEWS COVERAGE OF THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT AS I
SAID BEFORE, I THINK IT'S
BEEN A LITTLE LESS NEGATIVE
THAN A LOT OF OTHER TRUMP
THINGS BECAUSE THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THIS COULD WORK.
AND SO WHILE THERE IS A LOT
OF SORT OF A NATURAL
TENDENCY TO POO POO WHAT
TRUMP DOES, THIS ACTUALLY
MIGHT WORK.
I THINK A LITTLE BIT OF IT
HAS GROTON CAUGHT UP IN THE
COVERAGE OF THE G-7 COVERAGE
AND WHICH HE HAD A LOT OF
HIS COMMENTATORS SUGGESTING
THAT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
DESTROY THE WESTERN ALLIANCE
AND THEN THUS GOES WEAKENED
IN TO SINGAPORE.
BUT GENERALLY I THINK IN THE
LEAD UP TO THIS, WHILE THERE
WAS A LOT OF CRITICISM OF.
SO THINGS YOU JUST PLAYED
DONALD TRUMP SAYING THIS
ROCKET MAN AND THE FIRE AND
FURY STUFF, A LOT OF
CRITICISM OF WHAT HE DID
THERE.
WHEN THIS ACTUALLY CAME TO
THE IDEA OF AN ACTUAL
SUMMIT.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE WAITING
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.